[Applause]
[Music]
you know guys i was reading the news
this week and frankly it was depressing
i feel like every day there's another
story of a billionaire being horrible
and it feels like nothing ever changes
and there's nothing we can do about it
yep i agree it's it's like they're
almost untouchable i wish we could do
something well we could roast them
roast them
you mean like we can insult them as if
we were teenagers in a high school
cafeteria throwing inaccurate and
baseless insults about them rooted
mostly on looks and grouded in zero
facts
yes
and will it make us feel better i think
so
let's try it
okay so like
look at amazon founder jeff bezos oh
golf ball headed par 5 looking ass
bezos and is oh need to amazon myself
for toupee looking ass
oh dr evil cosplaying as lex luthor
looking ass
old e.t phone home riding the basket
looking ass
oh mr clean's dirtier cousin twice
removed looking ass
you're right
that did make us feel better uh do elon
musk okay
eli musk and his old backup kicker
looking ass
oh knows five people named skylar
looking ass oh just mansplained
mansplaining looking ass
oh i wish i was a real boy looking ass
oh is that bec bennett looking ass
wow
i'm feeling better already hey do mark
zuckerberg okay
mark zuckerberg and his old just saw the
miracle of birth video looking ass
oh peed the bed at a sleepover but kept
laying in it looking ass
oh peter parker who never got bit by a
radioactive spider looking ass
oh got embarrassed after biting into a
fake pair so we ate the whole thing
looking ass
oh childhood crush was pepper from
blue's cools looking ass
[Laughter]
we should probably stop we should
probably should
do bill gates
oh first name basis with his super cuts
barber looking ass
oh just got into bird watching looking
ass
oh way too into japan looking at
old inspired by revenge of the nerds
looking ass oh mack lamore's proud
father looking ass you know
it does absolutely nothing to change
anything but damn that feels good right
you should know with your old do the
right thing changed my life looking ass
whoa
okay actually that's me oh sorry i think
i've unlocked something inside me that i
do not know if i can put back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you